henderson man about to make his silver
screen debut starring in a movie with a
very powerful message about teen
bullying and suicide it's made its way
through the film festival circuits
grabbing multiple awards now it's
available for everyone to see in the
theater starting tomorrow
i'm never going to fit in professor
i got no friends the kids just look at
me and judge me the way i look high
school tough enough but for butter it's
a nightmare let me go eat it no i'm not
gonna eat plain butter the star alex
kersting makes his film debut hoping to
inspire and educate it's supposed to
start the conversation we want people to
you know end the stigma around mental
health depression and suicide the movie
rated pg-13 is based on a book an obese
teen decides he's going to eat himself
to death expecting pity he's instead met
with kids rallying around his plan of
self-destruction and begins to feel
popular you really think they're your
friends dude what's your problem i think
i'm gonna take your place well even if
you do i guess that spot will be back
open in january huh kirsten calls it a
dramedy that families should watch there
are
just kind of weird funny moments
the whole bucket list scene i think it's
going to be hilarious for most people
butter's one outlet is the saxophone
something kirsting a coronado high
school graduate had to learn for the
role but what you hear in the movie is
from another local it's to my uh
saxophone teachers track rocco barbato
who's also a local out here he worked
with donnie marie osmond at their show
at the flamingo he's incredibly talented
and he kind of helped bring
the personality of butter when he's
performing to life kersting says you'll
laugh and cry but leave with hope
there's always hope i think that's going
to be the biggest takeaway
always always hope the movie opens
tomorrow nationwide for now you can
catch it here at the galaxy theaters
inside the cannery in fact cursing says
he's going to be there tomorrow evening
he says he'd love to meet folks if
they're going to come and watch the
movie so really powerful message and
really a good film i laughed but you
said i cried a little it's it's it's
dark it is dark but it has a message
that i think you know especially in this
day and age so many families and even
young adults need to see
shout out coronado high yes indeed